centuries from now as archaeologists of
the future sift through the rubble of
our collapsed civilization i wonder what
they'll think when they uncover all the
statues memorials
murals to an ancient historical figure
named george floyd
if they're very perceptive they may even
note that hundreds of monuments to other
figures were torn down around the time
that floyd's monuments went up sometimes
the latter directly replacing the former
they'll conclude i imagine that floyd
was some kind of
history-shaping leader pioneer hero i
think he was a great man
perhaps one of the greatest men to ever
live this assumption will be
understandable given the evidence yet
totally wrong
george floyd we know was not a great man
or a good man or even a passively decent
man he was a violent felon and a drug
addict
celebrated as a martyr based entirely on
the manner of his death
which whatever else you might think
about it was not exactly heroic itself
the conversation around this man
especially now that the trial of the cop
charge and his death has begun
and will drag on probably for weeks that
conversation is hopelessly convoluted
there are really three separate
conversations
that have since last may been blended
together as one
there's the conversation about the
manner of floyd's death was he murdered
by derek chovin
and the conversation about floyd's race
and how it related to his death
if he was murdered was it racially
motivated and the conversation about
floyd's posthumous elevation
to the status of folk hero whether he
was murdered or not
whether it was racially motivated or not
is it good for us to celebrate this man
and plaster his face
all over our cities in his memory for
the media on the left
this is all one discussion with only one
acceptable point of view
yes floyd was murdered yes he was the
victim of racism and yes
he should be mourned and honored by all
people everywhere through all time
to them the final two propositions flow
automatically from the first if you ask
them
you know why we should honor george
floyd they'll say
well because he was murdered by a police
officer if he asked them how they know
he was the victim of racism they'll say
well it's because he was murdered by a
police officer
if you ask them how they know he was
murdered by a police officer they'll
just spit in your face and refuse to
dignify the question with an answer
this is why you cannot criticize the
hero worship of george floyd without
being accused of
defending the officer who allegedly
killed him they don't see a distinction
between his death and the hero worship
it's all part of a package
you're required to believe that floyd
was murdered
and that it was because of racism and
that he deserves to be honored in death
in the way that we honor civil rights
pioneers and war heroes
to stray from that narrative on any one
of those points
is to reject them all now of course in
reality
you might really reject them all and
there's nothing wrong with that
though it'll send the left in his into
hysterics who cares but the point is
that
one need not reject them all in order to
reject one
or two of them these are again different
conversations
different points of contention different
things entirely
as to my own view i think it is going to
be very difficult to prove that george
floyd was murdered given the fact that
he had chosen to put lethal doses of a
dangerous narcotic
into his system before he died if he had
not taken those drugs
and then resisted arrest resisted we
should note repeatedly and frantically
over the course of several minutes
he would most likely be alive today
floyd was also complaining that he
couldn't breathe before he was on the
ground and restrained
the prosecution will have to prove not
only that chauvin's actions were
negligently homicidal but that floyd
died from those actions and not from the
drugs
they haven't proved it yet we'll see if
they can
now i tend to hold the increasingly
controversial view that
murder cases should be decided in court
and that both sides should be heard from
before a verdict is decided as to the
other questions these are much clearer
to me
no george floyd's death had nothing to
do with racism
there is simply no evidence not even the
hint of evidence that derek chovin was
motivated by any racial animus
at all there is no evidence not even the
hint of evidence
that shelvin would have acted
differently had floyd been white instead
of black
there's also no evidence that police are
more likely to kill an unarmed black
suspect
more unarmed white suspects are killed
each year by police and when you examine
the statistical likelihood
that the arrest that's what you have to
look that's how you have to look at this
the likelihood that the arrest of an
unarmed black suspect will turn fatal
versus the statistical likelihood that
the arrest
of a white suspect will turn fatal
you're going to find that they are
almost
exactly the same also you'll find that
the category of
unarmed suspect is misleading in the
extreme as much of the time the unarmed
person quote unquote
was nonetheless in the process of trying
to kill the police officer
through some other means sometimes by
trying to take the officer's gun and use
it against him
the the racial element of the george
floyd saga is a fabrication
it is not based on anything other than
the left's blanket assumptions
which they apply to all police killings
indiscriminately
if a black man is killed by the cops no
matter the circumstance
it was because of racism that's what
they think
ten years ago i may have been
exaggerating had i summarized their
position that way
but not anymore that is really what they
think
finally should we be celebrating george
floyd
this again to me is clear cut no we
should not whether you believe he was
the
victim of murder or manslaughter or his
own choices or some combination of these
the fact remains that it's a disgrace
and embarrassment to our country to have
this man's face and likeness plastered
everywhere
it is gross to give a man like this an
elaborate funeral
a golden casket visited by weeping
dignitaries from across the country
remember the mayor of
minneapolis breaking down it can't even
can't contain himself breaking down in
tears
you know as if he was at the fu the
casket of his own child or something
the way that he was uh the way that he
was reacting it's insane
to spend a year mourning his death while
thousands of other people have died in
the meantime and the vast majority of
them
were far more deserving of our tears
than floyd
again this is the case no matter how he
died because the manner of his death
does not change the fact that this was a
man who preyed on members of his own
community he was a violent man a career
criminal
predator who should be alive today
simply because he never should have been
allowed out of prison
after he invaded a woman's home put a
gun to her stomach and robbed her
another man in floyd's group
pistol-whipped during the process
i mean think about that not not just
breaking into someone's house no no
forcing your way in at gunpoint
whipping a woman this wasn't a youthful
mistake but an act of barbaric cruelty
committed by a then 33 year old harding
criminal
and after serving an absurdly short
sentence for that crime i think he
served maybe six or seven years
or less he was released from prison now
the media tells us he cleaned up his act
at that point but it's odd that a
reformed man with a cleaned up act
would be high on fatal levels of
fentanyl while attempting to scam a
local store clerk with counterfeit bills
you know that to me doesn't sound like
reformation does any of this matter
in assessing the facts surrounding his
death no
none of it but potentially the fentanyl
matters for that
it does however matter in deciding
whether floyd should be canonized
that's where it matters and it's clear
that he should not be
or i should say should not have been
because it's already happened
and this point matters it's not
semantics we're not picking a dead man's
life apart for no reason normally this
is not a conversation that i would want
to have
i don't relish the opportunity to point
out the sins of the dead
i'm not going to find any random person
their obituary in the newspaper
and start examining and pointing out all
the bad things they did
it's not what i want to do is how to
spend my time but when you paint
giant murals of him and rename streets
after him
then it becomes necessary to think about
the kind of message that might send
now the irony here is that the left
certainly agrees with this in principle
because
they're the ones who've torn down
hundreds of statues of dead men
based on the alleged sins those men
committed
for floyd we have to ask do we want our
children to grow up in a world where a
violent felon
who victimized women and stole from and
robbed his neighbors is celebrated
and put forward as an example all
because he died while resisting arrest
and high on drugs
i would say no we don't at least i don't
i want my kids to aim a little higher in
life than that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content